yes I think the young entrepreneurs
needs to add the young generation needs
to understand their rights and the
responsibilities before we you know try
to change it by ourselves play they need
to be part of the change that's why we
need to educate them they need to be
taught that what is the responsibilities
also it's very important for them while
they are you know growing up and in
schools and in the universities to learn
their responsibilities and to learn that
they are they should be part of the
decision making and it's it's essential
for these you know young entrepreneurs
if they want if they become young
entrepreneurs to you know to start from
the beginning from schools from from the
universities and
this is part of what we should be
looking into in this conference that's
why there was some part of it about
education and how can we change
education and what can I education you
know be part of our be part of building
the young enterpreneurs